nathalie poutine économiste de la santé
maître de conférences en sciences
économiques et membre des économistes
atterrés et bonjour nathalie kutina
merci d'être avec nous ce matin sur rtl
france alors si l'on se réfère à
l'unicef un plus de 43 millions de doses
ont déjà été livrées aux pays
bénéficiaires
c'est encore très loin des objectifs
affichés
comment justement on peut faire pour
atteindre ses objectifs
alors c'est en effet très loin de les
objectifs affichés puisque même au
départ le programme kovacs l'idée
c'était que tous les achats soit fait de
manière groupée et qu'il soit ensuite
heureux distribué de manière équitable
entre les différents pays mondiaux alors
évidemment c'est pas le cas puisqu'il ya
eu un nationalisme vaccinale qui s'est
fortement opérés notamment au niveau des
pays les plus riches qui sont évidemment
ceux qui avaient la plus grande capacité
à acquérir ce vaccin ainsi les 10 pays
les plus riches se sont partagés trois
quarts des doses de vaccins disponibles
donc effectivement c'est totalement
inégalitaire et inacceptable à la fois
d'un point de vue social éthique mais
aussi parce qu'on voit bien que lorsque
toute la population mondiale n'est pas
vacciné et bien les risques de
transformation de nouveau variant est de
retour de d'épidémie encore plus ravagés
dans les pays du nord existe justement à
nathalie continent est ce que ça ne
serait pas l'apparition ces variants et
qui ont peut-être
mis un coup d'arrêt justement à ce
programme kovacs et qui a renforcé
peut-être d'un côté le nationalisme des
vaccins dont vous parlez et je porte
quel nationaliste vaccinale il existe
plutôt depuis le début puisqu'on voit
bien que les etats unis le royaume uni
et l'union européenne ont commandés
massivement des doses de vaccin et que
c'est plutôt aujourd'hui alors que tout
le monde se rend compte que si la
vaccination n'a pas lieu dans tous les
pays
eh bien les variants risque de pas se
développe à risque de revenir que on
commence à se rendre compte de la
nécessité de vacciner les autres
populations les populations des pays
intermédiaires et des pays les plus
pauvres
alors maintenant que l'on sait que
l'objectif est loin d'être réalisée
comment on peut faire justement pour
améliorer l'accès aux vaccins dans les
pays les plus pauvres dans la mesure où
pour le moment il manque encore de doses
c'est le problème majeur est bien il
faut que l'on renonce les pays riches à
certaines doses pour vacciner les pays d
autres pays ou alors et c'est la
solution qui me semblerait être la plus
intéressante c'est d'obliger les
laboratoires pharmaceutiques à renoncer
à leur brevet de manière à ce qu'il
puisse y avoir une production beaucoup
plus importante de ce vaccin de ces
différents vaccins production plus
importante qui permettra de répondre à
la population mondiale
malheureusement pour le moment et en
dépit de tout l'intérêt qu'avait kovacs
kovacs et quand même porté par des
acteurs notamment la gates foundation
qui font du respect de la propriété
intellectuelle un élément majeur de la
stratégie alors il ya quelques temps la
france a fait don de 100 mille doses au
programme
kovacs justement où en est la france
justement dans ce programme par rapport
à d'autres pays donateurs
la france participe elle participe
d'ailleurs assez tardivement de manière
bon sens 1012 sais c'est bien mais on
imagine bien que quand on à 92 pays du
sud
plus le dpi interview
vacciner c'est une toute petite goutte
d'eau dans l'océan des douze nécessaire
pour ces pays là donc il faut que
beaucoup plus massivement tous les pays
interviennent pour aider les pays du sud
à vacciner aujourd'hui pfizer annonce
plutôt des augmentations de prix de son
vaccin
il a même le dirigeant de father amaldi
qui pourrait aller jusqu'à 150 dollars
la dose
on voit bien que dans ces conditions là
aucun pays du sud ne pourra acheter des
doses et que évidemment les pays du nord
ne peuvent continuer à le faire
donc il ya une vraie inégalité de ce
point de vue là mais encore une fois la
solution passe sans doute par une
réflexion sur la propriété
intellectuelle des médicaments ou des
vaccins dans le cadre de tel pour délit
est justement comment a commencé citer
les pays donateurs à donner davantage
malheureusement je sais pas la solution
sans doute que la peur de la maladie la
peur du retour du vernis sera la plus
grande et on voit que la france a
commencé à bouger et moins c'est moins
les questions finalement éthiques et
morales qui font bouger les pays plus
que des questions égoïste de peur de
retour encore une fois des différents
variant sur les sur les territoires
merci beaucoup et nathalie goutines est
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin et
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes économiste de la
santé
maître de conférences en sciences
économiques et membre des économistes
atterrés merci beaucoup